this is well we showed you this at the
top of the show but let's just throw
back to this you'll see why
is Admiral Rachel Levine and I have the
honor of being the assistant secretary
for health at the United States
Department of Health and Human Services
happy Pride happy pride month and
actually let's declare it a summer of
Pride happy summer of Pride yeah let's
not you freak but okay let's continue so
then
uh so then it continued here's dick
Levine talking about how gender
affirming care is actually Suicide
Prevention care and I'm going to blow
your mind with something on the other
side of this one go you know we often
say the gender affirm and Care is Health
Care gender affirming care is mental
health care and gender affirming care is
literally Suicide Prevention care would
that be your view as well I 100 percent
agree and I know statistically
speaking that the
uh regret rate for gender affirming
surgery is about one percent and that is
significantly lower than the regret rate
for general surgery like a knee
replacement oh well you asked some
random kid whether he agrees about that
so I guess it is we we now know that
many many people and it is going to
continue to break this way that many
many people who go under these
transitions which doesn't change your
biological sex even though they pretend
it does but they chop your breasts off
chemically castrate you hormones all the
other problems with that you end up
having a penis that doesn't work a
series of other health problems blah
blah blah you may not look as the way
you want on the other side of the whole
damn thing now all of these people are
suicidal or depressed there's a huge
detransition movement now the ultimate
irony of this dick Levine is that dick
Levine has is on video we've showed it
to you before literally like three years
ago I think it was maybe it was four
years ago I think it was 2019 dick
Levine on video saying how happy he was
that he didn't transition until he was
an adult because he has kids so do you
know what that means dick Levine had a
dick it's unclear to me if he has one
now frankly I don't care and I don't
want to know dick Levine had a dick
impregnated his wife that he was married
to for 30 years they have kids then at
the age of 50 whatever he decides to be
a woman again I don't know if he'd
chopped the Wang off or not but now is
pushing that other children should not
what he described as his greatest joy
his two children as his greatest joy and
he is now pushing with this entire
Administration this clown car of crazy
people the idea that children should be
doing this to themselves
[Music]
thank you